apologize we're going to add in Brett
Alex Salmond who has with the solicitor
there which mr. Sammon raised very much
as a last resort in August the Scottish
government has now conceded that it
acted unlawfully in circumstances which
were procedurally unfair and tinted with
apparent bias against my client they've
agreed to meet the legal costs as part
of their concession on the one hand mr.
Sammon is happy that his decision to
bring this case to court has been
vindicated but on the other is saddened
that had had to come this far this
process has come at considerable cost to
the taxpayer which mr. Sammon finds
deeply troubling he has maintained a
dignified silence throughout the process
and made it very clear that he would
respect the decision of the court he
will now take some time to digest this
decision and consider his legal options
mr. Sammon will now say a few words and
take some questions
thank you very much David I thought so
obviously like to thank my outstanding
legal team I'd like to thank my family
and my friends for standing with me over
the the last few months I particularly
like to thank the more than 4,000 people
who've contributed to the code funder
who made this court action possible and
I'll be writing to them this afternoon I
made it clear that if there was a
surplus and the fund it would go to good
cause he's in Scotland at home under and
abroad and given that I was likely know
to be a surplus in the fund given the
concession of expenses by the Scottish
Government to the maximum extent and
that will no be done I'm thinking on
three things the last time I was in that
court it was to be sworn in as First
Minister of Scotland I never thought it
possible there any point I'd be taking
the Scottish government to court
and therefore while I'm glad about the
victory which has been achieved today
I'm sad that it was necessary to take
this action the consequences are very
clear because the process has been
agreed as unlawful as unfair and tainted
by a pardon bias then the Scottish
Government have had to concede on the
case and on the expenses to the maximum
extent that is going to raise a cost to
the public posts of many many hundreds
of thousands of pounds and all of this
was unnecessary because throughout the
process we offered mediation legal
arbitration so that this battle could be
properly settled without having to come
to the highest court in the land at
every stage that was rebuffed by the
permanent secretary I notice in their
submissions that the advocate for the
government said that the government
accepted institutional responsibility
not personal the institutional
responsibility and therefore I suggest
that the permit is sent to the Scottish
government no accepts that
responsibility and considers our
position can I finish the statement
German then of course I'll take some
questions
the second question is lack of candor
this case turned and came to a
conclusion by the total surrender of the
government's position because of the
documents Commission ordered by Lord
Pentland which met between Christmas and
New Year where several servants under
oath had to produce hundreds of
documents which the government had
refused before that to provide to the
court I would have thought a public
authority given what these documents
show
and these documents for now at least are
under the protection of the court
we've not have required a court order in
order to have the transparency and
openness and to allow the case to be
settled on its merits and thirdly I'm
struck by this fact I've been deeply
troubled throughout the case by the
leaking of confidential information by
whoever any complaints process has to be
transparent transparent balanced and
fair and confidential that's the
interests of the complainers and those
complained about we have a process or at
least hard-won in the scottish
government called fairness at work I
know about it because I introduced them
thank goodness that is still in force at
least for civil servants as opposed to
the total mess which was introduced by
the permanent secretary but if
confidentiality is breached then it
undermines the entire process and
obviously that was done in terms of
leaks the tabloid newspaper and also
crucially by a leak of the purported
advice of the Lord Advocate bleaching
the essential requirement of the
separation of criminal justice from
politics something which I have never
seen done in recent Scottish history
presumably these leaks were deliberate
and malicious and yet the family safety
for the Scottish government has refused
to hold an inquiry into where these
leaks came from oh no my summary would
be this I'm obviously glad delighted by
the result today the government have
made an abject surrender in terms of the
case before we even got to the first day
of hearings before Lord Pentland I'm
just sad that it was necessary to take
this action in this court to session to
prove that point back in August
I made my last comments and these
matters I said that the process that was
used against me was unfair unlawful and
biased by tainted by bias I also said
that I was not guilty of any criminality
the first of these has been established
the second is to come but a former First
Minister of Scotland requiring to take
the administration of the Scottish
government to court to establish that
point should not have been necessary and
the person who is responsible for that
that institutional failure
the permanent safety to the Scottish
government should consider her position
and take the appropriate action and I
thank again my legal team can I thank
again my family and my friends and the
people who supported this case glad to 1
and sad but it's been necessary